Indiana Jones in the dial of Destiny
why just why well I know why it's money
but still this movie is effectively
about uh Indiana Jones post-retirement
having his goddaughter show up and talk
to him about this dial that her father
Indiana's best friend supposedly was
obsessed with which actually has this
really funny flashback this is Flashback
where you see Indie uh kind of
middle-aged ish talking to goddaughter's
Dad and he's like I found something that
can change time which is the dial of
Destiny and Indiana Jones is like you're
a Madman that's insane
like Indiana Jones hasn't seen insane
didn't he see aliens like what are
you talking about why does that make him
a Madman but uh Chase chaos in shoes and
they go on the hunt for the second piece
of the dial actually in order to destroy
it so the bad guys the Nazis can't get
their hands on it and this movie is
um somehow exhausting and kind of boring
at the same time which is really
disappointing so to get like something
that I feel really strongly about out of
the way Harrison Ford does such a good
job he's not generally known for being a
heartfelt actor it is a heartfelt
performance in that he as a character
has to sometimes talk about feeling old
and it kind of it's kind of like a gut
punch because you know that Harrison
Ford feels the same way like he is too
old to play Indie that is a reality of
watching this movie you are watching a
bunch of old men uh including people
from previous films you show up which is
a delight talk about how they're too old
to do this knowing that Harrison Ford
really loves playing Indie
um made that kind of feel even more real
like he knows that he has to hang up
Indy in the same way that Indiana Jones
has to hang up being an adventurer and
it already has but his performance is
fantastic he's very endearing and while
they do their best to still have him be
an action hero um in a way that
actually becomes cartoonish at certain
points he's not supposed to be a
superhero they definitely play him like
a superhero with the ridiculous stuff
that he gets up to overall Harrison Ford
is a delight to watch does such a good
job and I'm happy for him that he got to
play Indie again even if I feel like
this movie didn't need to exist he's
Scrappy and he's lovable and they don't
overplay
him needing too much help like I was
worried from some of the trailers that
um his goddaughter who is played by
Phoebe Wallop bridge I think that's how
you say her name that she would be too
handholdy or she would like rescue him
like he was a damsel in distress kind of
thing they didn't do that thankfully
they both rescue each other a fair
amount of times and while I found her
character to be obnoxious and annoying
and you know if you don't take that
issue with um her particular performance
you'll probably like this movie a lot
more than I did I just found it really
really grating it is like a partnership
that that uh logically doesn't make a
ton of sense and they only Loosely
thread their relationship but uh Indy
himself does have a nice emotional Arc
and I think like pretty well understands
the character that they're saying
goodbye to you with this movie
definitely found that part of it to be
sentimental
um but it's shrouded in something that's
just like kind of annoying the movie is
just an elaborate Chase sequence which
isn't unlike how it's existed in
previous Indiana Jones movies or how it
exists in Uncharted or or any of this
particular genre of careless treasure
hunter right that's something we've seen
a bunch of times and it certainly exists
here but the chase sequences in this
movie are so frequent and so long that
they become boring I think this might be
the first time in my life that I have
been bored by action sequences just
because of how uninteresting the action
is and how frequent they are and how
long they last it can't be easy to make
something action-packed boring but it
lacks any actual thrill so there are no
genuine Thrills in the action it's not
gripping to watch any of it it's just a
woman on a bike again maybe they're on a
plane this time it's a train and I do
consider that maybe some of that stuff
that ends up becoming like tedious and
boring could be because we've seen it so
many times which is because of Indiana
Jones But ultimately the reality for me
is that I just think Spielberg knows
what he's doing when it comes to adding
visual humor into those Thrills and
making it feel like there are stakes and
making things feel triumphant and making
sure Indiana Jones doesn't feel like a
superhero he feels like a real man who
fails sometimes Mangold who directed
this iteration of Indiana Jones I don't
think succeeds at doing it the Thrills
aren't there the visual humor isn't
there the same level of chaos isn't
there it's just a lot of like kind of
cartoonish in some cases chases which is
also definitely paired with cartoonish
villains fairy OneNote comically one
note it's kind of a disservice I think
to um even like the intellect of Indie
that it's just so much of this like
really pretty goose chase where it's
like one of them has it and then the
other one has it oh wait no this one
knows where they're going but they're
tracking them oh this one figured it out
they can track them back it's just so
much chasing people on vehicles you know
just so much and none of those moments
feel particularly
uh magical it's like if you gave chat
GPT Indiana Jones I'm aware that chat
GPT couldn't actually write a screenplay
like this but it's basically like it has
all the Staples of what it thinks
Indiana Jones is but doesn't execute on
any of the heart of what Indiana Jones
is outside of Harrison Ford doing such a
good job with the character and that
definitely escalates towards the end the
finale is like so outlandish that it's
absurd it's so absurd it's really really
just silly and it I don't know I can't
get it out of my head that it feels like
this is what happens when almost nobody
involved in making the original Indiana
Jones films makes Indiana Jones it feels
like it's made by committee and
realistically that's the truth again
outside of Harrison Ford thank God he's
in this movie and so ultimately actually
my takeaway wouldn't be that this movie
is bad I did find parts of it boring I
did find the chase sequence is boring I
really don't like the performance from
Phoebe wall bridge it's not a bad
performance I just found it obnoxious
grading a little bit annoying a lot of
like kind of that's my best impression
of what our character does it's a lot of
smirking but it does it's not a bad film
um I think it's just dull it's just dull
and I will say Jesus Christ everybody
just all of you the execs who are
definitely watching this video stop with
the Deep faking the first sequence of
this film has a younger Indiana Jones uh
de-aged Harrison Ford who oddly enough
you know could not change his voice so
it sounds really odd so much of it looks
terrible and there are some moments
where it looks almost okay and then you
hard cut to another human and it you go
oh and it starts that way and I feel
like every time I see this I forget what
they're even saying because I'm so
distracted by how terrible they look
which you don't want to happen with your
film it does not look good in some cases
it looks awful in some cases it looks
okay but you still know what it is it
almost looks like a good video game it
doesn't look like a human and there's
maybe I don't know maybe 15 minutes of
it at the start like Jesus and that was
the point where I was like this is kind
of fun I'm kind of on board with this
but I had to like make myself pay
attention to what they were saying
because these goddamn shots of Harrison
Ford face just looking awful that was
the worst thing about it similarly to
flash the best thing about this movie
again outside of Harrison Ford was the
score John Williams did a fantastic job
at the school surprising nobody punching
in the right places it's uplifting it
makes the again Chase sequences that I
largely found to be very boring a little
bit more comical and tense and dramatic
and I feel like John Williams understood
the assignment he understands the
essence of Indy in a way that I feel
like the director he probably did not so
much and that's the most that I feel
like I can say about Indiana Jones but I
do find it to be dull and boring
um which is wild for an action movie and
to really lack a lot of the on point
humor and heart and Spark and charm that
Indie should have that Harrison Ford
just manages to carry anyway because
he's done such a fantastic job so I
didn't have great expectations going
into this based on uh the reviews being
pretty negative but I didn't expect to
find it boring I so rarely find movies
boring and I was but I in the cinema
checked the time to see how long it had
been I don't think I've ever done that
in a film before if you like Indy for uh
an adventurer going on adventures with a
nice John Williams score you'll like it
if you like Indie for the way that
Spielberg directed these films with that
Flair and flavor and sense of humor and
sort of Sparkle thrill you probably
won't like this movie I don't think all
fans are going to dislike it they'll
just be certain camps where you feel one
way or the other and I didn't go in with
high expectations but I think ultimately
yeah I'm like disappointed
it's a real bummer
Harrison Ford
did a great job should I also review
Mario and spider verse while we're at it
because I really did like those I just
feel like it's harder to find a lot to
say about movies that you like it's
easier to talk about things you have
criticisms of I mean I do have
criticisms of both of those to be fair
but yeah I don't know if I could make a
long video about them I don't know what
I would have to say I don't know let me
know I'm alone I'll see you guys next
time bye